I like the story about when you skived
off school to do your the big audition
for new faces yeah which was the big
kind of talent show at the time yeah new
faces was like x-factor the voice but
for Britain's Got Talent actually had
judges and everything and I've been
nominated to go on by DJ Mike my manager
and I smoked had to sneak out of the
house early because mom didn't know I
was gonna play truant from school I'll
put on my Sunday school clothes because
there were the best clothes I had when I
went to Birmingham to this club with a
very sticky carpet the smelled of we
waited all day and then at 6 o'clock I
went onstage and it was the most
glorious thing the judges have been
saying next all day but this was the
first time we hadn't said next and
suddenly I had the golden ticket and I'd
got through and it was fantastic and DJ
Mike drove me back home to Dudley and he
saw my mom's silhouette in the window
and he drove off really quick so I went
to the front door and mum was standing
in the front door where you been
audition
what kind of hardy tion I went through
auditions on new faces new faces hmm
what dear impressions what you mean
impressions do it now what so she made
me do the impressions on my front
doorstep if you want to come in this
house and eat chicken rice and peas and
your gravy a better dream presence right
now very much a bizarre start the show
I was a joke the other day if you take a
volley closest um by the window I said
why is it across on my neighbor's here's
a funny this is max bar games you've
never heard of Max bar games IV or the
melon Millennials then what's Lenny
talking about but there was this guy
called max bye guys
and he used to talk like this I went to
the dentist the other day he said saying
ah
I said why suddenly dogs did then there
was a Michael Crawford has a show cause
some mothers do album and the
ploughman's lunch the other day it was
furious I did this thing was wonderful
was my family my cousin's my brothers
and sisters get me a round of applause
and it was the first time that
acknowledged that I was this other
person yeah I wasn't the Lynne from
inside the house
I was Lenny from outside the house
outside the house did this stuff with
his mates and it was a kind of
revelation but it was also a wonderful
homecoming for me yeah because they
suddenly started to go yeah a lens the
one who does the voice
[Music]
you